hey guys my name is Jess this is Dan and
you are watching games but news if
you're longing for just one more weekend
day sorry I can't help you but if what
you want is another day in the destiny
beta we've got you started the open beta
for bungees upcoming sequel that carries
on the story of Marvin the Martian after
he hit the gym and got serious about
world domination has had its beta
extended until Tuesday the 25th of July
at 6 p.m. PDT if you're yet to jump in
on ps4 or Xbox one you can play through
the opening homecoming mission and the
inverted spire 3 Guardian strike if
you're a PvE fan but if you want a
little taste of PvP you can jump into a
match of countdown on endless veil and
control on Midtown if you're wanting to
see how this one performs on PC there
will be a PC beta
sometime in August make sure you
subscribe so you don't miss us telling
you about it when it drops and all the
other video gave me stuff you'll find in
between if you got your heart set on
picking up a shiny new Xbox one X it
sounds like Microsoft just about ready
to let you do that Xbox boss Phil
Spencer tweeted a reply to a gamer who
asked when the Xbox one X pre-orders are
set to release to that Spencer said our
plan is set for this all approvals are
done so now just landing the announce
with all the info won't be too much
longer do you remember when those
listings do go live the Xbox one X is
slated to run you 500 bucks in the u.s.
449 euro in Europe and 649 dollars in
Australia it seems like a lot more than
the other two
the Xbox one X is launching on November
7 worldwide so maybe that extra hundred
fifty bucks is because we get it a day
early also the delivery guy has to get
past all the drop bears as if you needed
more reasons to play Zelda breadth of
the wild after the release of the tingle
outfit members of the mod community Funi
are working on a co-op mode for the
games the mod is being developed using a
Wii U emulator for PC and currently only
works on a single PC with local controls
there's still a lot of things that need
to be figured out explain ready Iza /
that's just how inventories are going to
work and the logistics of two players
completing the game's shrine I wouldn't
hold your breath on this one either as
it sounds like it's still a long time
away with one of the developers saying
it could take years not to me
Nintendo's penchant for shutting down
fan-made projects what do you think of
this one would you play a multiplayer
breath of the wild let us know in the
comments below that is everything I've
got for you today but the others know
what you thought of today's stories down
in that comment box we'll see you guys
tomorrow